hey there fellow Geeks I'm Debbie and
today I have the brand new Apple iPhone
14 plus in my hands and it's in the
happy yellow color and it's perfect for
the summer it's a powerful device no
doubt and what summer with a great
device without some awesome games to go
with it combined with the Apple arcade
service Apple users has access to a
wealth of games and I'll be checking out
my top 5 favorite games from the latest
20 titles that just dropped on the
service Apple arcade is a subscription
service that offers a library of over
200 games that can be played on the
iPhone iPad Mac and Apple TVs there's a
free three month trial right now to
enjoy these great finds without having
to watch a single advertisement and
there is absolutely no in-app purchases
now let's get into our top 5 of the new
20 releases on Apple arcade that you
shouldn't Miss but before that git
culture is supported by Brands who help
improve this channel so help us out by
staying around for this message here at
geek culture we've tested plenty of
Chess but Secret Life gaming chairs
remain one of our favorites whether it's
for work or play they feel great to lean
back against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head and back
to the arms and even something for your
butt this mix of format function helps
the Titan Evo 2020 to deliver the best
seating experience like no other for
more information check out secretlab.co
starting off our list at number five we
have snake IO a modern Twist on a
classic
PC you can now have it available on the
go snake IO is an addictive multiplayer
experience where you compete against
players from around the world to become
the longest and bigger snake on the
board your objective is to accumulate as
many pellets as you can to grow inside
or eliminate other snakes by getting
them to collide into your body and be
the biggest snake outmaneuver other
snakes to survive and avoid colliding
with extreme ends of the map my strategy
is to trap other snakes within my body
honestly this is one of the more
addictive games as it makes you want to
keep beating your previous high score
there is also a stun big button that
pops up occasionally for you to enter
the game bigger and faster the
replayability factor of this game is
immense as snake IO offers endless hours
of fun and intense competition and you
are able to unlock up to 60 different
skins just look at it my personal
favorite is books next up at number 4 we
have Octodad Deadliest Catch this is
probably one of the more peculiar
slapstick humor games you've ever played
in this hilarious and unconventional
Simulator game you play as an ordinary
dad who also happens to be an octopus in
Disguise your objective is to maneuver
through daily tasks without exposing
yourself the controls are actually quite
tough Octodad has two sets of tentacles
mimicking arms and legs you have to
switch between the two with a single
button to move octodad's tentacles each
of the four tentacles is controlled
independently mimicking the coordination
needed for walking and interacting
coordinate your movement carefully to
maintain balance and move in the desired
Direction octodad's movement is
intentionally exaggerated and imprecise
and is part of the game's charms keep an
eye out on characters around you their
line of sight and any potential hazards
that could expose your true nature move
with caution and avoid causing
disruptions experiment with different
movements strategies and approaches to
find out what works best for you couch
Co-op is also available where each
player controls one of his four
tentacles simply connect your Bluetooth
devices such as the Nintendo joy-con or
PlayStation controller to your phone a
sign who controls which tentacle and
begins experience the chaos of trying to
navigate your way around to complete the
chores typical of a mundane Suburban
father the quirky gameplay clever
puzzles and storyline made up to that
Deadliest Catch and absolute blast to
play absolutely hilarious but also
anxiety inducing moving on to number
three we have very little nightmares a
hauntingly beautiful puzzle platformer
with a beautiful storyline that will
keep you on the edge of your seat
immerse yourself in a dark and
Atmospheric world as you guide a
courageous goal in the yellow raincoat
bravely through treacherous environments
and solve intricate puzzles despite not
having the same visuals as the little
Nightmares on PC or Playstation very
little nightmares still gives off the
same Eerie and unsettling feel while the
PC and Playstation is a 3D based puzzle
game the mobile version is grid based
which utilizes touch-based controls tap
on the grids in order to move the girl
in the yellow raincoat the puzzle
solving is still as interactive and
somewhat challenging but the mobility
and the option to move freely hinder the
game a little as the game progresses you
will navigate through various Eerie yet
atmospheric environments do not forget
to pay attention to the surroundings
solve puzzles and explore the
environment to progress further look for
Clues and manipulate objects to overcome
the the obstacles in your path
throughout the game there will be
enemies and hazards that can harm your
character stay alert and avoid the
detection or find ways to outsmart them
the game also has frequent checkpoints
where you can save your progress all in
all this game is still a fun one however
the PC and PlayStation version still
outshines the mobile version because of
the coordinative controls the challenge
and of course the Sinister graphics and
now coming up in second place we have a
top-down roguelike game Teenage Mutant
and Ninja Turtles Splinter fate a game
that brings our favorite Heroes and a
half shell to the Apple arcade platform
join Leonardo Donatello Raphael and
Michelangelo in a captivating Adventure
filled with action stealth and epic
battles against their arch nemesis the
stunning Graphics engaging combat system
and nostalgic charm of TMNT splintered
feet make it a must play for any Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles fan
the introduction is short and gets into
the game very quickly you start off with
one of the four Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles characters Leonardo learn how to
use the controls with the introduction
guide and level up Leonardo as you go
execute combo attacks and special moves
and utilize each turtle's unique
abilities and attributes to defeat
enemies enhance your combat skills and
increase your overall power to defeat
Shredder as you retrieve back Master
Splinter complete various missions tasks
and objectives assigned to you
throughout the game not to mention you
get to pick the rest of the Ninja
Turtles such as Michelangelo Raphael and
Donatello to engage in battle each total
has unique abilities strengths and play
Styles complete the game in story mode
or use multiplayer mode to play with
your friends online tackle missions
together and engage in competitive
gameplay
for our top pick at number one is
Kingdom 2 crowns I know you're gonna see
many other recommendations from these 20
games and I guarantee you this game is
unlikely to be on any top 5 list but
that's where you'll be shortchanged if
you don't give this game a try
this is a 2D pixel art side-scrolling
microstrategy game where you embark on a
royal adventure to build and expand your
kingdom with this beautiful pixel art
immersive soundtrack and strategic depth
Kingdom 2 crowns offers a compelling and
addictive experience rule your domain
recruit loyal subjects defend against
enemies and discover the secrets of the
Kingdom in this enchanting game as the
game starts you'll find yourself in the
woods as a monarch on his horse this
ghostly figure then brings you to a
campfire site where you start building
your Empire explore and identify Key
Resources such as coins and workers that
will help you build and expand your
kingdom
these villages will become workers who
gather resources and construct buildings
Defend Your Kingdom from enemies by
constructing and upgrading buildings
such as walls farms and Archer towers
and expand your Kingdom's infrastructure
what is crucial for your survival and
prosperity at night your kingdom will
come under attack from various enemies
prepare your defenses by recruiting
arches Pikeman and Knights by providing
them with bows Pikes and catapults
Venture beyond your Kingdom's borders to
uncover new lands find hidden treasures
and unlock additional resources and
power-ups there are multiple maps to
conquer and in all maps are various
docks and Cliff portals to destroy one
thing we truly enjoyed about this game
is how you choose to strategize your
gameplay best part rule your kingdom
with a friend as couch Co-op is also
available just go into the split screen
option and play it with the on-screen
touch controls or connect external
controllers via Bluetooth cast your
phone's screen sharing onto your smart
TV connect your external controllers and
you have yourself a console game and
there you have it my top 5 Apple arcade
games that are definitely worth playing
whether you're an avid gamer or simply
looking for some casual entertainment
these titles will keep you hooked and
entertained for hours Apple arcade
offers an incredible selection of games
that cater to all tastes and preferences
with subscription at just 6.98 a month
to Apple arcade you gain access to a
vast library of high quality games
ensuring that you never run out of
exciting experiences to enjoy and the
best part you can play across all of
your Apple devices seamlessly and this
gives you an up to five friends
unlimited access through Family Sharing
not forgetting three months of free
trial first so don't miss out on this
incredible gaming experience join the
Apple arcade Community today and unlock
a world of entertainment and Adventure
thank you for joining me today I hope
you found this video helpful in
discovering the amazing games and
benefits of Apple arcade until next time
happy gaming